Trump vs DeSantis number one what do you
want to happen number two what do you
think will happen
it's a great conversation we've had it
many times I don't think it's pretty I
think it's going to be ugly I think it's
uh this is a part where I'm going to
kind of agree with you on give you
something that you're going to be able
to talk about I think there could be a
civil war on the Republican side I don't
think it will be pretty and I think if a
DeSantis or a trump is wise specifically
more on The Descent side you have to do
negotiations up front before 2024 comes
around meaning
my Camp is sitting down with Trump's cam
right now having conversations
to see if we can do anything here
because if Trump comes out doing what
Trump's going to do it's going to be you
know how Bernie came out calling out
Biden calling out Warren calling out all
that stuff but guess what Bernie did at
the end of the day
he brought them back and he fell in love
there's no way so this is gonna happen